is uh rap music absolutely have you
evolved on this or uh have I evolved on
this um so again I'm going to go to
what's the definition of Music my
original argument about rap was that
music involves the following three
elements Rhythm Melody Harmony rap
typically involves maybe one of those uh
there there may maybe a Melody maybe
sometimes um so it depends on the kind
of rap uh with that said I I could be
convinced on this issue but listen I'm
I'm a classical violinist I mean that's
how I was raised I listen to bethoven
and brahs and moart like in the car with
my kids so is it comparable is in the
same category as bethoven brahs and
Mozart I have a very hard time sticking
it in the same category is
that